all right why don't we get why don't we
get started it's uh
2 35
time to begin
so everyone welcome i'm back good to see
you all
and um
well this is a few of you
glad that you're here
um uh
so um
let's see
why don't i uh
get a layout as i usually do what
where we have been where we're going
today i'll talk a little tiny bit about
the homework because i've gotten a
couple questions on that
and then we'll jump in uh so we have
been um
talking about turing machines which is
going to be our
preferred model for the rest of the
semester since turing machines are the
model which we use to capture general
purpose general purpose computing
and we looked at
turing machines and various
um
variations on turing machines
multi-tapes non-deterministic and so on
um
it's a bit recapping
the history of the subject when people
looked at
a variety of different ways of
formalizing the notion of algorithm
and they
showed that all of those
different formalizations were equivalent
to one another which led to the church
turing thesis
that all of these models each of these
models really capture our intuitive idea
of what we mean by
a
procedure or an algorithm um
first for at least for addressing um
you know things like mathematical
problems and and precise uh precise
problems of that kind
so we talked about the church turing
thesis we also talked about a notation
for encodings and turing machines we'll
review that briefly
so today we're going to give a bunch of
examples of
turing machine algorithms for solving a
variety of different problems i should
just say algorithms are really nothing
special about turing machines during
machines are just going to be our formal
counterpart but from now on we're going
to use our um church touring thesis in a
way to just to talk about algorithms in
general because that's really our
interest turing machines is just you
know our way of
reasoning about them mathematically but
we're really ultimately interested in
understanding algorithms
um i'm gonna
in terms of the format of today's class
i'm gonna try a little experiment um
we're gonna have little breaks along the
way and uh in as well as the big coffee
break in the middle uh we're gonna have
a little mini breaks um because i
sometimes feel that there really isn't
enough time for people to be writing
chat uh you know questions in the chat
um
because things just are racing on and so
this way we'll have a little break after
the they have pretty much after each
slide some of them will be a little
longer than others for in case you have
questions you can pose them to me or to
the tas and we'll try to get back to you
on those
so um moving on then so today just as a
quick review uh
turing machines as we set them up
they have
on any input w they have three possible
outcomes the turing machine can hold and
accept
w can hold and reject w
or it can go forever on w which is
rejecting by looping in in our language
a turing machine can recognize a
language
the collection of all strings that it
accepts
and if the turing machine always halts
we say it decides the language and it's
a decider
and so therefore that language is a
decidable language or turing decidable
often we just say decidable because we
don't really have a notion of deciding
in other
models so we often talk about touring
recognizable or just decidable well
we'll sometimes just say recognizable
when we understand that we're talking
about turing machines
we briefly talked about encodings
um
when you write it inside brackets some
objects whatever they are it could be
strings could be machines could be
graphs it could be polynomials
we're representing them as strings
and maybe a collection of objects
together represented as a string
in order so that we can present that
information as an input to a machine
and we talk about
our languages or collections of strings
and a notation for writing a turing
machine is going to be simply that
english description
put inside quotation marks to represent
our informal way of talking about
the formal object that we could produce
if we wanted to but we're never going to
ask you to do that
okay um
so now um
let me see uh
let's just take a quick break as i
promised um
um
if there's any quick questions here you
can ask
[Music]
um
uh let's see
we get a lot of questions here um
all right why don't we move on and uh
some of these things are good questions
if there was something um
you know somebody asked can you how do
you tell if the machine is looping or if
it's really just taking a very long time
um
you can't
that's what we're gonna prove
not in today's lecture but we're gonna
prove that on thursday um
and so
that's uh you just can't tell so you're
gonna if if that's in reference to
problem five you're gonna have to find
some other way of doing solving that
problem without knowing whether the
machine is actually ever going to hold
um
and
somebody asked how can we tell if an
english description is possible for a
turing machine well i mean
um you can always
write down an english description uh for
any machine um
it's uh might be very uh
technical looking but if you can write
it down in a formal way as states and
transitions then you can certainly write
down an english description which would
just be follow those
follow those states um
okay let's let's move on um
so uh
okay this is going to be our first
example
of a
um algorithm that's going to answer a
question about automata
um
and it's a very simple problem it's a
very simple um
problem to solve because we want to
start out easy
um
and it's the problem we'll get the name
of the problem is the acceptance problem
for
deterministic finance acceptance problem
for dfas
and i'm going to express it as i always
do as a language
so this language here i'm calling it a
dfa which stands for the acceptance
problem for dfas
is the collection of pairs
b and w
b is it is a dfa
w is
uh considered to be
some other string which will be an input
to b we'll say well me thinking of it as
an input to be i put the two of them in
brackets to represent the pair of them
as a single string
and it's the you know we're not going to
make explicit what the form of the
encoding is the only important thing is
is that the encoding should be something
simple um but that the turing machine
can decode back into
the
dfa and this input string to that dfa
so
anything reasonable is going to be a
satisfactory encoding from us for us
so this is an encoded of the two of them
into a string and where b is a dfa and b
accepts w
so now if you want to test
if something's a member of adfa a
then
first of all you want to make sure that
the string itself that you're getting
really encodes
a dfa
and a string so it has to be of the
right form
and
uh once you know that
then you have the dfa you have the
string w
and you're then gonna do the obvious
thing which would be to simulate b on w
and see if it's actually accepting w
okay so that's that's what the content
of this slide is i'm just going to write
it down for you um
so i'm going to give a turing machine
which i'm going to call i'm going to
give the name of that turing machine
it's going to be d adfa
to help you remember
the function of this machine this is a
decider
for the language below the adfa language
this is just a name but so nothing fancy
going on here but just to help us
remember because i'm going to refer to
some of these during machines later on
so this is the decider for adfa and i'm
going to describe that machine for you
and that machine decides the adfa
language
um so what does that mean so that
machine i'm describing and now you in
english as i promised
i'm going to take an input string s
um and first it's going to check that s
has the right form
uh as i mentioned has the form which is
the encoding of a dfa and a w
um if it's not of that form the turing
machine should reject that input right
away
now i'm not going to go through the
details of how that turing machine is
going to work though i'll say a little
bit more this time this time only just
to give you a sense of how it actually
might carry that out
but you should believe that if you don't
believe it you can do it with a turing
machine believe you could do it with
your favorite programming language
that's good enough because that's going
to be that's equivalent to a turing
machine
so first you check that the inputs are
the right form then you're going to
simulate the computation of b on w
and then if b ends up in an except state
then we know b is accepting the input
and we should accept and we do
if b does not end up in an accept state
at the end of the end of w
um then we should reject because b is
not accepting w
okay that's my description of this
machine
let's just turn to a little bit of
details just to make sure we're
comfortable with this um
so here is our turing machine
d the decider for adfa
the input to the turing machine as i
mentioned is going to be
uh b and w provided it's of the right
form so that's what the string s is
supposed to be of that form um and what
does that mean it's just an encoding of
the of the machine w and the string
the machine
b and the string w
so here is
let me just write it down here is b
written down in some just completely
explicit way where you're just listing
the states of b
the alphabet of b
the transition function as a table the
start state and the set of um accepting
states just writing it down explicitly
as you might do it if you just want to
describe that machine in a completely
formal way
and then writing down what the string is
um whatever it is
once
d8fa has that as its input it can then
go ahead and do that computation
and you know just
to try to make it a little bit more
explicit i'm going to capture that here
by saying let's
give
uh that turing machine an extra tape
because we already know that the
multi-tape model is equivalent to the
single tape model make it our life
perhaps a little easier
and in the course of doing that
simulation what do we want to keep track
of well what is the current state of
uh b
the dfa as we're reading the the the
symbols of w
and where in w are we at right now so
i'll call that k which is the uh input
head location on w how many symbols of w
have we read
okay and that's what all i'm going to
say about uh what this turing machine d
looks like
but i'm happy to
um
oh there's one more thing i do want to
say further that's coming up um
uh because
pretty much all of the turing machines
that we're going to talk about today and
and going forward are going to often
want to check that their input is of the
correct form i don't want to repeat this
every time because that's going to be
kind of assumed so my shorthand for that
is to say my input is of the form i'm
looking for
and that has built into it the check
that the string the input string is of
that form and we're going to reject if
it is if it is not
so all of our turing machines are going
to start out
on input the string is of a certain form
and then go on and do something with it
okay um
and uh
i thought this is a good way to um
uh
okay so let me try to answer a few of
the questions um that that i've gotten
here uh
um
because i think this is important as a
way of getting us all started
um
now somebody asked me can we use
arguments of this form
um
ken is somebody asking can we use can we
uh
give our description of a procedure if
i'm understanding this correctly as
uh using some other programming language
well typically you just want to make
sure you're understood
if you want to do that on a homework i
wouldn't advocate writing your
algorithm in in java because it's just
going to be hard to read but to write it
down in some
pseudo programming language if you want
just to make sure it's clear that what
what you're doing um probably english is
going to be the easiest for you
um
um
even though this person says he feels it
would be easier to do it in terms of a
formal language well whatever's easier
as long as we can understand it
um now what another this is a good
question here that i got asked what if b
uh here's our b gets into a loop
on w
well that's not going to happen b is a
dfa dfas
on an um
they move from from state to state every
time they read a symbol of w
when they get to the end of w it's the
end of the story there's no more
computation to be done
so we know in exactly how many steps b
is ever going to take on it's going to
take the same number of steps as the
length of the input
that's how many moves it gets to make so
there's never b as the dfa never loops
so that would be a problem if it did
loop but it doesn't and there that input
never does a loop
so have we verified that d as a decider
well i think i just did
d is never going to be
this d
from my standpoint we've said enough
to be sure that d is a decider um
uh there's never any reason for d to be
for
that dadfa turing machine to be getting
into a loop um
the input head location is referring to
where we are on the string w yes
[Music]
and somebody's asking me is this the
level of detail for the homework yes
that's all i want it's all i'm looking
for
okay um
[Music]
let us move on uh
i'm gonna have to
uh otherwise never get anywhere there's
a lot of questions here they're good
questions
um so why don't we uh go on some of
these may get resolved as we're going to
look at additional examples because
that's all of today is pretty much
examples
uh let's talk about the similar problem
the acceptance problem but now for
anaphase
um
so now actually anaphase can loop um so
we have to think about what that
possibly could look at but let's
before we get ahead of ourselves so now
the acceptance problems for anaphase
looks very similar except b is going to
be an nfa
that's going to be a decidable language
too
um
and now we have turing machine a
d
a n f a the decider for a nfa that
decides a nfa
okay so now
uh as promised here is my new form for
writing our turing machine on input bw
we're we're assuming that b you know
based on on the context sometimes you
may want to say at this point what b and
w are but from the context we know what
they are they're going to be an nfa and
an input w for that nfa
oh so
what um i don't want to jump into the
solution uh
first before we actually look at the
solution of this we could you know d
uh the turing machine could simulate the
nfa on input w and you have to be
careful on that simulation that you
don't end up looping um because don't
forget
uh
an nfa could have um epsilon moves and
could be looping on those
epsilon moves and so
that would be a problem if you're not
careful about how you do that simulation
um
now i think if you were going to
simulate an nfa
um
you would be
you wouldn't follow
around loops forever um
uh and i think you can uh without
getting because this is not the way i'm
going to solve the problem you could
find a way to avoid getting caught in in
getting stuck in loops for an nfa um
so
uh even though
um
that looks like it could be a problem in
terms of looping forever it turns out
that it won't be a problem um
it wouldn't be a problem if you're
careful
but i'm not going to solve it that way
anyway because i'm going to illustrate a
different method for solving this
problem and that is we have exhibited
before a way of converting anaphase to
dfas
so my turing machine
is going to solve the a n f a problem by
converting its input which is an n of a
to an equivalent dfa i'm calling the
nfab and the dfa that i got converting
it into b prime
and what's nice about that is that first
of all we already know how to do that
conversion because we um
we essentially went over that in lecture
a few lectures back
and it's spelled out in full detail in
the textbook so that is a conversion we
know how to do we'll assume we know how
to do
and we can
implement that during that conversion on
a turing machine
then once we have the equivalent dfa
what do we do with that
well we've in the previous slide we
showed how to solve the problem for dfas
so if we can convert the anapha to a dfa
and then we already know how to solve
the problem for dfas then we're then
we're done so that's how i'm going to
say we're going to convert the nfa to a
dfa and then i'm going to run that
dadfa
problem on the new machine that i
produced
so remember that the um this machine
here decides the adfa prop
and now i'm going to accept if that new
machine uh if that if that previous
turing machine accepts the a dfa the the
adfa problem um
machine accepts
and um i'm gonna i'm gonna basically do
whatever it does if it accepts i'll
accept if it rejects then i'll reject
um
now um
this is
um
[Music]
uh
so
i guess the thing that this illustrates
is this idea of
using a conversion construction inside a
turing machine
and then a previously constructed turing
machine basically as a subroutine
um
all this is perfectly legal and it's the
kind of thing we're going to be doing a
lot of and that you should be used to
doing that get ready to be doing that on
your homework too
um
and in fact i'll give you a another
little extra hint that problem six can
be solved in this way
okay um
all right so here let's pause briefly um
uh
okay uh
got some interesting questions here
coming up um
uh
you know do somebody ask me do we meet
do we need to be explicit about how
we're going to simulate that uh nfa or
the dfa because we don't know how many
states it has
not knowing how many states you
you do know how many states it has once
it's presented to you on the input you
can see oh this is a machine that has 12
states
because you're given the machine
and then you can do the simulation
um let's see um
and someone is asking me about limits on
the simulation power of a turing machine
uh
that's a question that i'm going to
postpone to later because you're asking
if a turing machine can simulate itself
and we'll talk about things like that
but that's you know in in a few weeks
from now so i'll
hold off on that one um
decidable languages the collection of
decided somebody's asking me a good
question about closure properties of the
class of decidable languages are they
closed under intersection um union and
so on yes
the design
and
the decidable languages are also closed
under complement that should be
something you should think about
but yes that is true
um the recognizable languages however
are closed under union and intersection
but they are not closed under complement
um
so that would that we will prove on
thursday's lecture
so another question is could we have
just run b on w in this in solving this
problem instead of using the reduced
converting it to a new turing machine a
new mission
the b prime well you know yes we could
have just done that um i'm
okay
i think we better move on uh i don't
want to get too bogged down um here
got a lot of questions there so sorry if
i'm not getting to all of the questions
okay um
or you can write to the tas too
obviously i'm sure you are
okay so let's talk about a different
problem
emptiness problem for dfas
okay um
so
now we have here i'm going to give you
now a just
a dfa
b
and no input
and i'm going to ask
is the language of that dfa the the
empty set the empty language
you understand the problem first of all
i'm just handing you an um a dfa and i
want to know does this dfa accept any
strings at all or is it just some
dumb dfa it's just always
very negative dfa it just rejects
everything
um and has the empty language
okay how do you tell
not super hard um if you think about how
you would write a program to do that
or how you do it yourself
so that's a decidable language again um
so gonna give it now a touring machine
decider for that language
um
that decider says
uh well
i'm given that
dfa i want to know if its language is
empty
and the idea is just kind of what you
would think i'm going to see is there a
path from the start state of that dfa to
the an except state of the dfa if there
is such a path
then that dfa is going to have an input
which goes along that path and will be
accepted
and so the language won't be empty
there's no such path then clearly this
dfa can never accept anything
and so the language will be empty
okay now there are many different uh
you know
there are many different path algorithms
um i think would be a little bit
uh sparse of me just
you know
some of you know path algorithms some of
you don't know path checking algorithms
i would like you to just to if you were
giving this kind of an answer on
homework to give me some sense of how
that algorithm is going to work
um
don't be too high level about it
so the one i have in mind is kind of
breadth first search er
if you've heard of that but uh it's very
simple algorithm what i'm going to use
is a kind of a marking procedure so i'm
going to start off by coloring
the
here is this i should have indicated
this is my
dfa b
this is b over here um
should i try
taking a chance of writing on this thing
oops
this is b
oh great
that didn't help
uh
so this is b here and the way i'm going
to
test if it has a path if it accepts any
input is by seeing if there's a path
from the start state to any one of the
except states and i'm going to start it
by marking the start state and then
marking all states that i can get to
from previously marked states
and keep doing that i can't tell i can't
get to anything new
okay so here
there's going to be like a series of
iterations here marking more and more
states until there's nothing new to mark
and then i say did i mark any except
states
okay so let's just see how i write that
down in english
um
so i started marking the start state
uh i repeat until no new state is marked
and that
uh
i'm going to say mark every state that
has an incoming arrow from our
previously marked state
um accept and then once i'm done with
that repeat loop except if no accept
state is marked because that means don't
forget it's a little bit inverted from
what you might think i'm going to accept
if there's no
marked accept state because that means
there's no path
to an accept state from the start state
which means the language is empty
and edfa is the
dfas that have empty language so i
should be accepting those
so except if there's no um way to get to
an accept state no except status is
marked and rejected if some accept state
is marked because then the language is
not empty
okay so that's all i wanted to say about
that
um
can you somebody's asking can you just
say it's something like breadth first
search
as long as you know
the sketchier you are the more chances
that you're going to get caught by the
greater um who's knocking who's going to
be
um you know we have an army of people
grading these problems
and just to stay on this be on the safe
side of sketchiness
and say don't cut too many corners
because you might miss something um
chances are would be okay just to say
breadth research but you know i would
prefer if you you'd be safer if you said
a little bit more than that
okay
oh
um this is a good question here uh
somebody asks uh can we just run the dfa
on all shorts on all strings well first
of all
you know one thing
um to say something bad would be we'll
just feed in all possible strings into
the dfa
and if any one of them except if it
accepts any one of them then we know its
language is not empty
well that's not a good algorithm because
that's going to potentially run forever
um because you know there's lots of
strings there's infinitely many strings
to feed in to that um to that dfa and so
a turing machine
you know if it's trying to be a decider
had better not do any infinite
operations that are potentially going to
go forever um
now this is to be fair to the uh
proposer here the questioner here didn't
ask that says well can we feed an old
strings up to some bound um which would
be the number of states of the machine
in this case and yes that would work but
then you would have to argue
that that's enough
and yes
it is enough um but it wouldn't would
not be enough in answering the problem
just to say
feed it in that number of them and you
know we're done you would have to say
what
um
um
okay um
uh
um
a lot of questions here i'm gonna i'm
gonna move on uh
uh let's see equivalence problem for
dfas
now we're going to take take things to
the next level ask are there two
um uh i'm going to give you two dfas
and i want to know do they describe the
same language do they
do they recognize the same language
okay um
[Music]
so how are we going to do that
so that's a decidable language um here's
the decider
um
[Music]
my input now is going to be two dfas
again represented as a string because
that's what turing machines deal with as
their inputs
but they can unpack that string into two
dfas
and
there are several different ways to do
this problem and i'm sure i'm going to
get uh suggestions with other other ways
to go one thing you could do
is uh just to feed
in
strings up to a certain length
well because you can't just like before
you can't feed in all possible strings
and see if the machines ever behave
differently on any of them um because
that's infinite an infinite operation
and we're a decider we can't do that now
if you're if you want to talk about this
being a recognizer instead of a decider
then you might be able to do something
like that just to make sure you're end
up
you have to be just careful
um let me not say more on that right now
but
certainly for a decider you can't go
forever you can't have infinite
operations
um so
uh you would have to have a cutoff
so you can feed in all possible strings
up to some length say
into a and b and see if there's any
difference now we actually had a problem
on that in the whole in problem set one
um which said if two two dfas have um
unequal languages then they're going to
see a pl a difference that there's going
to be a string which acts differently on
them which is of length at most the
product of the number of states of those
two machines
so it
you know you can either reference that
uh problem that would be an out that
would be an adequate solution or reprove
it or whatever that would be fine in
fact there's you can do even better than
that as the optional problem showed you
only have to go up to the sum of the
number of states not up to the product
but that's actually very difficult to
show
but i don't i'm not going to prove it
that way
i'm going to prove it an entirely
different way which doesn't require any
analysis at all
no proofing proving something about
bounds um i'm going to take advantage of
something we've already shown
and which is i'm going to make a new
fine art automaton a new dfac
built out of a and b
which accepts all the strings on which a
and b disagree
i'll show you how to that's easy to do
so first of all let's in terms of a
picture let's understand what this is so
here we have this is the language of a
this is the language of b
written as a venn diagram and where are
those places where they disagree
um well they're you know either in a but
not in b or in b but not in a i'm
showing it to here in terms of the blue
region
um that actually has a name called the
symmetric difference
of these two of these two sets these are
this
this all of the members which are in
exactly one out of the two but not both
if you can make a machine c that would
accept
uh all of the strings in the blue region
then what do we do with that machine
we test if its language is empty
which is what we've already shown how to
do because if the blue region is empty
that means that l of a equals l of b
okay so
i'm going to make a machine a dfac where
the language of c is exactly that
symmetric difference it's all the
strings in a
intersect with the strings that are not
in b so in a and not in b or
in b and not it then not an a and take
the union of those two parts
and how do we know we can make c well we
have those closure constructions
which we showed several lectures back
those closure constructions can be
implemented on a turing machine
so a turn machine can build the dfac
and then
use that test from
a few slides back the emptiness though
last slide the emptiness tester for dfas
on c to see whether its language is
empty and now if c's language is empty
then we know we can accept because that
means the two the l of a equals l of b
otherwise we can reject
okay
so here's a now i'm going to ask you a
check
um you can also use that time to send me
a few more questions if you want
okay here's my check-in
okay now instead of testing equivalents
of finite of dfas i want to test the
equivalence of regular expressions
um
to
r1 r2 regular expressions are called the
eq regular expressions problem
equivalence of regular expressions can
we now conclude that this problem is
also decidable
either
immediately from stuff we've already
shown or yes but would take some
significant extra work or no because
intersection is not a regular operation
so let's see if i can pull that out here
launch the polling
um
here we go
okay i think we're just about done here
um
five oh five seconds more
okay ready set end
all right
yes the ant's correct answer is a we
have basically already shown this fact
um
because
what why is that because we
have shown that we can convert if you're
given two regular expressions and we
want to test whether they're equivalent
or whether they generate the same
language we can convert them both to
to finite automata
we can convert them to n phase and then
the n phase to dfas
and um then we can apply what we just
showed
about testing equivalence of dfas
so yes it really follows immediately
from stuff we've already shown the
conversion number one and then the
testing equivalents for dfas
um so there's not really any work to do
here and in fact what i'm trying to
illustrate
with this uh check-in
that once you've shown um how to do some
kind of a test for one model it have
going to apply for all of the equivalent
models that we've that we've shown to be
equivalent because the turing machine
can can do the constructions which show
the equivalence
um
okay uh so let's move on um
somebody didn't get the pole
did most people not get the pole
well i think most of you have gotten it
did you
i'm not seeing a lot of complaints so if
you didn't get the poll something is
wrong with your setup and you're going
to have to take the recorded uh uh
check-ins um that are
going to launch right after this lecture
is over sorry
but we just you should figure out what's
wrong with the setup there because i
think most people are getting these
okay
and with that we're going to take a
little break
and then we'll continue on afterwards
now let me know how this is is this
slowing us too you know should i
be speed a little speedier about the um
the
about the little mini breaks that we're
taking or um is this good for you
you know feedback is always i'm trying
to make this as good as i can for for
all of you
okay i i think there's a mixture between
people saying that these breaks are good
some says they're a little a little over
long so i'll try to
tighten them up a little um some some
some folks are saying what
more people should be
uh
asking the tas i don't know how the tas
are doing in terms of their i'll check
with them afterward how well this is
going for them in terms of uh questions
but i think some amount of break is good
um
so that we don't uh so there's time to
be asking asking questions um otherwise
what's the point of having a live
lecture
so we will start promptly
when this timer runs down
um so
uh
be ready to go in 55 seconds from now
just to confirm to show the decidability
of the equivalence of two regular
expressions do we need to show that we
can use a turing machine to convert them
to dfas first
well
i mean any procedure that you can give
if you want to test whether two
regular expressions are equivalent
you can give any procedure for doing
that deciding you want
um i'm just offering one one simple way
to do it that takes advantage of stuff
we've already shown but if you want to
dig down and do some analysis of those
regular expressions to show that they
describe the same language they generate
the same language be my guest i think
that's actually would be complicated to
do that that way okay so we're just
about um ready to go here
uh so let's continue um
uh
and let me take this timer off here
um
all right
now
we are going to talk a little about
context-free grammars
so we talked about decision problems for
finite automata let's talk about some
for grammars um
okay now i'm going to give us an
analogous problem i'm going to give you
a the except i'm calling it the
acceptance problem but just just for
consistency with everything else but
it's really the generating problem so
i'm giving you a grammar g a c a context
free grammar g
and a string that's in a string and i
want to know is it in the language of g
so does g generate w
i'm calling that the a cfg problem
so that's going to be a decidable again
so now let's just think about how that
these are getting slightly harder as
we're moving along
so i'm giving you
a
grammar
and a string
and i want to know does the grammar
generate that string
um
well you know it's not
totally trivial
to solve that
you know one thing you might try doing
is looking at all possible things
all possible derivations
from that grammar
and see if any one of them
leads to w
leads you to generate w
well you have to be careful
because
uh as i as we've shown in some of our
examples
um you actually could have um
because you're allowed to have variables
that can get converted to empty string
you might have very long intermediate
strings being generated from a grammar
which then ultimately give you a small
string of terminals that get generated
a small string in the language that gets
produced
and so it's not clear how you know you
certainly don't want to try every
possible derivation because there's
infinitely many different derivations
most of them generating of course things
that are irrelevant to the string w
but you have to know how to cut things
off
and it's not immediately obvious how you
do that
unless
you have
done
the homework problems that i asked you
to do which i'm sure very many of you
have not done the zerobot point x
problems because there that's going to
come in handy right now
and so i'll i'll help you through that
um
remember i'm hoping you should remember
but you may not have looked at it
uh something called chomsky normal form
which is for context-free grammars
but only allows the rules to be of a
special kind and they have to look like
this they can be a variable that goes to
two variables
on the right-hand side or a variable
that goes to a terminal
those are the only kinds of rules that
you're allowed
there's a special case for the empty
string but let's ignore that you know
for if you have you want to put the the
start variable can also go to the empty
string if you want to have a
the empty string in the language but
that's that's a special case let's
ignore that
these are the only two kinds of rules
that you can have in the chomsky normal
form gram
once you have a chomsky normal form
grammar
um well first of all there's two things
first of all you can always convert any
any context free grammar into chomsky
normal form so that's given in the
textbook
it's very it's sort of the you do the
obvious thing
i'm not going to spend time on it
and you don't have to know it it's it's
kind of just a little bit um
tedious but it's it's straightforward
and it's there if you if you're curious
um
but the second line is the thing that's
important to us
uh which is that if you have a grammar
which in is in chomsky normal form
and a string that's generated
every
derivation of that string
has exactly
two times the length of the string minus
one steps
it's actually if you think about it i
mean this dilemma is very easy to prove
um i think the homework problem
asks you to prove that in the
0.2 or whatever it was um and problem
set one or pub set two when i remember
um
because you can in order to do you know
rules of this kind allow you to make the
string one longer and rules of this kind
allow you to produce an uh an x a new
terminal symbol
and so you're really going to end up
having um
you know if if the length of w is n
you're going to have n minus one of
these and n of those that's why you get
two n minus one
steps but the point is i don't really
care exactly how many it's just that we
have a bound
and once you have that bound
life is good from the point of view of
um
giving a turing machine which is going
to
decide this language
because here's the turing machine what's
going to do with the first thing is it's
going to convert g into chomsky normal
form
that we assume we know how to do
now we're going to try all derivations
but only those of length
2
twice the length of the string minus 1.
um because if any derivation is going to
generate w it has to be this this many
steps
um
now that we know the grammar is in
chomsky normal form
okay so
we have converted this problem of one
that might be a very
unboundedly
lengthy problem into one way you know
it's going to terminate after some fixed
number of steps
and so therefore we can accept if any of
those uh generate w and reject not
okay and so oh so this is uh before
moving on so this uh answers the problem
shows that this language is decidable
the the acfg language
okay so that's something that
you know make sure you understand
um
uh
we're basically trying all derivations
of up to of a certain length because
that's all that's needed when the
grammar is in that form now we're going
to use that to prove a corollary
which is um
which is important for understanding how
everything fits together
and that corollary
states that every context-free language
is a decidable language
every content-free language is decidable
now why does that follow from this
well
um
suppose you have a context-free language
a
we know that language is generated by
some context free grammar g
okay that's what it means
so then
you can take that grammar g and you can
build it into a turing machine so
there's going to be a turing machine
which ha which is
uh
um
constructed
with the knowledge of g
um
and uh that turing machine is going to
take its w
and run the acfg algorithm
um with w combined with the g that's
already built into it
so it's just going to stick that grammar
g in front of w
and now run the ac of g decide
it's going to say does g generate w
well that's going to be yes
every time w is an a
and so this machine here now uh is going
to end up accepting
every string that's in a
because it's every string that g
generates
okay so um
uh
that is i think what i wanted to say
about this now
i feel that this corollary here
throws a little bit of a curveball
curveball um and um
uh we can just pause for a moment here
just to
uh make sure you're
understanding this
so let me
the tricky thing about this corollary
is
that i often get uh a question i often
get
where is
you know when we start off with a
context-free language
who gives a w how do we get g
because we need g to build the turing
machine um m sub g
so we know a is a context free language
but how do we know what g is
well the point is that
uh
we may not know
what g is but we know g exists
because that's a definition
of a being a context-free language
it must have a context-free grammar by
definition
and so because g exists
i now know my turn machine m sub g
exists
and that's enough to know
that
a is decidable because it has a decider
that exists
now if you're not going to tell me the
grammar for g
i'm not going to tell you
the turing machine which decides a
but i know that but both of them exist
so if you tell me g then i can tell you
the turing machine
okay so it's a subtle
tricky issue there a certain little
element maybe of sometimes people call
it non-constructive because we're just
in a sense showing just that something
is existing but um
you know it does the job for us because
it shows that a is a decidable language
okay so not so many questions here maybe
the tas are getting them so let's move
on um here's another check-in
uh
so now can we conclude that a
instead of a cfg a pda is decidable
hey
people are getting this one pretty fast
another 10 seconds
three seconds
okay i'm gonna shut it down
um
end polling
share results
yeah you know i
uh
so this
uh
problem here is apda is decidable it's
really in a sense i was almost wondering
whether or not to give this poll because
it has it's true for the same reason as
the as poll number one um because we
know how to convert pdas
or we stated we can convert pdas to cfgs
and you know that conversion is given in
the book we didn't do in lecture but i
just stated you have to know that fact
but not necessarily know how to do it
that's okay but the fact is true
um the conversion is in the book and it
could be implemented on a turing machine
so if you want to know whether a pda's
language is empty you convert it to a
context-free grammar and then use this
procedure here to test whether it's a
language
not empty i'm sorry
the acceptance problem i just want to
not accept i just want to know does the
pda accept some input
i'm saying it wrong so i want to know
does the pda accept some input i convert
that pda to a grammar
and then i see if the grammar generates
that input because it's an equivalent
grammar
um so again this is using the fact that
grammars and pdas are equivalent and
interconvertible from one to another
just like regular expressions in dfas
from the previous poll
so you need to be comfortable with that
uh because we're going to not even talk
about it anymore we're just going to be
treating those things going back and
forth between them without sometimes
without even any comment
okay
so let's move on uh
emptiness problem for cfgs hopefully
you're getting comfortable with the know
you know the terminology i'm using um so
now the emptiness problem for
context-free grammars
i'm just going to give you a grammar and
i want to know if its language is empty
okay so
remember we did this refined automata by
testing a path
can't you know we don't really have
paths here
you might think testing pairs and push
down automata that's not going to really
work because the stack is there so how
are we going to do that test well
there's something sort of like testing a
path um just working with the grammar
itself kind of working backwards from
the terminals now um i'll kind of
illustrate that here
here's imagine i'm giving you here's a
very simple
grammar and i want to know
does it generate
any strings any strings of term
obviously
only care about strings of terminals
because those are the things that are in
the in the language
so does this grammar generate any
strings
of terminals
so what we're going to answer that is by
a marking procedure but in a sense we're
going to start from the um from the
terminals and work backwards to see if
we can get to the start variable
so first we're going to mark all the
terminal symbols
and then we're going to mark
anything that goes
to a string of completely marked
symbols either terminals or variables
because anything that's marked we know
can derive a string of terminals that's
what it means anything that's that's
blue can derive a string of just
terminals and so now if you have a
collection of those
that are all marked
they together can generate some you know
string of terminals
um together
and so then you can mark the associated
variable so like t goes to a so that may
be over simple but we're going to mark t
here everywhere in the grammar so all
these t's are going to get marked
because we know that t can generate a
string of terminals
now let's take a look at r
r is going to a string
of symbols that are all marked
and that means those symbols can in turn
generate the strings of terminals so we
can mark r2
we can't get mark s because we don't
know yet whether s has some unmarked
thing that it goes to so we don't know
yet whether s can generate a string of
terminals but r we know right now so
we're going to mark r but we then now
that gets us to mark this r and so then
we can go backwards and we can mark s
and we keep doing that until there's
nothing new to mark and here we've
marked everything so clearly there's
nothing more you can mark but you might
stop before you've marked everything
and then you
see
whether you've marked the stark variable
or not and if you have you know the
language is not empty
okay so let's just go through this in in
in in text
for mark all occurrences of terminals in
g
then repeat until no new variables are
marked we mark all occurrences of
variables
a
if a goes to a string of symbols
and all of those symbols were already
marked
because those are the things that
already have been shown to generate a
string of terminals
and so now we're going to reject if the
start status start variable is marked
because that means that the language is
not empty and except if it's not
okay
so
um
let me just just i'll take a couple of
quick quick questions here
okay somebody
um
somebody asked whether
uh
if i understand other regular languages
also decidable well remember the regular
languages are context-free languages and
the context-free languages are decidable
so yes the regular languages are
decidable um
okay i don't know some of those are
going to be too long to answer and
they're trying to come up with
alternative solutions so i think we're
going to move on
um
all right we talked about
um
just like we did for the final automata
we talked about acceptance we talked
about emptiness we talked about
equivalence
so how about the equivalence problem for
context-free grammars
i'm going to give you now two
context-free grammars
and i'd like to know
are those two contexts free grammars
generating the same language
so how might you think about that
well
you know one thing uh you know following
some of the ideas that we've already had
um
you could try
feeding strings in to those grammars we
know how to test whether those
individual grammars can generate those
strings so you can just try feeding
strings in
to g and to h
and seeing whether those grammars ever
disagree
or whether they generate some string
find some string that say g generates
but h does not generate and we can test
that string by string
unfortunately we've got a lot of strings
to test
right that's gonna you know we we would
need to give some bound
if we were going to use that for a
procedure
not clear what the bound is
um
another idea
um
might be to use
the
uh closure construction
uh
that we had from before um so let's
let's mull that over um whether that
might work um but in fact um
[Music]
uh
let me give away the answer here
um
this language is not decidable
there's no algorithm
out there no turing machine but
therefore no algorithm
which can take two grammars
and test whether they generate the same
language or not
seems at first glance kind of surprising
such simple things as context-free
grammars can nonetheless be so
complicated
that there's no procedure out there
which can tell whether the two gram
those two grammars generate the same
language we will show that um
next week
a related problem which is related to
your homework
this uh that's due on
uh thursday uh is testing whether a
grammar is ambiguous
so given a grammar i'd like to know is
is that grammar and ambiguous
grammar or not i mean does it generate
some string
you know in the language of that grammar
in two possibly different ways two or
more different ways
so is there some string um that can be
generated
you know with two different parsers
um
so um the problem of testing whether
grammar is ambiguous
not decidable
so i'm asking you to do something hard
something hard
when you have to produce
that grammar which is unambiguous for
that language um in general
testing whether grammar is ambiguous or
not is not a decidable problem now
hopefully that the grammar that you'll
produce
uh
to show that um you know to get that
unambiguous grammar for that language
that i'm asking you to produce is not
going to require our graders to solve
some undecidable problem that it'll be
clear based on the construction of that
grammar why it's uh not ambiguous so
you'll have to hopefully say some
some explanation of what you're thinking
there
uh
okay um so that's uh
uh and we will prove
that uh the problem of testing ambiguity
is not decidable that's gonna be a
homework problem in problem set three
um okay uh
let's check in here kind of something
that i alluded to but didn't quite
didn't want to give away
uh why not use the same technique
that we use to show equivalence of dfas
is decidable to show that equivalence of
context-free grammars is decidable
obviously something goes wrong because
eqcfg is not decidable why doesn't that
same technique just work
um
well um
what's the answer
oh this is
got a real race here
another 15 seconds this one
it gives you something to mull over
um
all right let's end it
okay you're good to go
at least click something um okay ending
polling
sharing results
okay a bunch of you have thought well
cfgs are generators and dfas are
recognizers and that's the issue well
not really
because
you know you can
we could test
um
equivalence
of regular expressions those are
generators it's nothing to do with being
a generator or not um
um because you know we can convert
regular expressions to dfas and then and
then test equivalence for the dfa so
that it's not really a matter of a
matter of being generated that's not the
issue
the issue is that we can't follow the
same construction that we did to show
eqdfa as decidable because the
context-free
languages are not closed under those
operations we needed to make that
symmetric difference machine
if you remember how that worked
so then i closed under complementation
and not closer intersection we needed
both
in order to build that machine c
um which accepted all the strings that
are sort of in the difference
okay
so let's continue on um
let's move now to turing machines
uh this is where stuff is really going
to start to get interesting
i'm not hoping it's been interesting all
along but maybe even more interesting um
so
let's talk about the acceptance problem
for turing machines atm
this is going to be because this
language is going to become an old
friend
we're just getting just getting to know
it
uh so this is the problem you're given a
turing machine now in an input
and i want to know does m accept that
input
that term does that turning machine
accept its input
um
okay
so that's
going to not be a decidable problem
either so it kind of shifted gears from
a bunch of decidable things to a bunch
of undecidable things
so this is not a decidable language
we will prove that um
on thursday that's going to be the whole
point of thursday's lecture is proving
that atm is undecidable and that's going
to be really a jumping off point for
showing other problems are undecidable
um so that's going to be our first uh
proof of undecidability
um
but we do know
that atm is
recognizable
and that's worth
um
understanding
um for multiple reasons but for one
thing it's going to give us an example
of a problem which we know is
recognizable but not decidable as we
will as will prove undecidability but
it's also
um i think
of
of
of historical importance um
uh
uh this this algorithm for showing it
recognizable so let's go through that
algorithm for it's very simple sort of
doing the obvious thing um
the following turing machine i'm calling
you going to call it u
for a reason that i'll make clear in a
second
that's going to be a recognizer for atm
so it takes as input
an m and a w
and it's just going to simulate m w
pretty much the way
the
um
algorithm the the decider for adfa
worked
but now
the machine instead of being a dfa it's
a turing machine and the turing machine
might go
forever
and so the simulation may not stop
and that's the key difference which
makes it from a decider into a
recognizer
so that simulation um
so you're going to be simulating just
keeping track of the tape of m the
current state of m
um where you know and
proceeding
to modify the tape as m modifies it and
then
if m enters an accept state
then you know m is accepted as input so
you also will enter and accept state so
the machine u
enters the accept state if m observes
during the simulation that m enters an
accept state
uh furthermore if n m enters a reject
state
then u also enters a reject state
okay
now i want to say something beyond that
which i i want you to
pay attention to
um
which is the kind of thing i do see
sometimes people saying
uh we want you to reject if m never
holds
i mean that's also seems like what we
want
because if it never holds then m is
rejecting by looping so you should also
reject
but i don't like that
i don't like that line here
step four of the turing machine
because there's no way for a turing
machine to determine or at least as we
no obvious way uh and in fact it will
not be any way but certainly at this
point no obvious way for m to even tell
for you to tell whether m is holding or
not
uh well certainly tell that is to say it
never holds how can you make that
determination so this is not if i saw
this on a um
on a solution either on an exam or a
homework i would mark you off
this is no good
it's not a legal touring machine action
if m
does not hold on w
um then you should reject
that is correct and you can make that
reasoning external
to the
algorithm of you
but you is going to end up rejecting
because it never holds either
it never actually knows
that m is rejecting w in that case if m
is rejecting by looping it's just
blindly going along and doing the
simulation of m on w
um and we'll end up holding rejecting by
looping if m is rejecting by looping but
that's something that you can argue
if you need to make a proof or make some
sort of reasoning about the machine but
it's not part of the algorithm of the
machine
um
okay now what what's i think from a
historical standpoint it's interesting
about this machine you and why i'm
calling it you
is because this appeared this al this
machine you
appeared in turing's original paper
where he laid out turing machines he
didn't call them touring machines by the
way he called them computing machines
people afterward called them turing
machines
uh
but uh turing called this the universal
computing machine that's his language
actually i just looked at the paper
yesterday um just to refresh my memory
of it um and he gives the description of
the operation of view in gory detail
with all of the transitions and the
states he nails the whole thing down
takes pages and pages and pages
so he gives it gives it there
um so this is the original universal
uh computing mission universal turing
machine and this
it's more than just an idle curiosity
that disappeared in touring's paper
because this actually turned out to be
profoundly influential
in the in computer science because it
really was the first example of a
machine that operated based on a stored
program
it really was a revolutionary idea in
the in those days if you wanted to make
a machine that did something different
you had to wire the machine rewire the
machine
but here's a machine that operated based
on instructions
um
and the instructions in a sense are no
different than the data uh so this is
what's been
come to be known as the von neumann
architecture but von neumann himself
gave credit to turing machine for having
inspired inspired him to think of this
and some people argue that it's really
calling it the binomial a bunch of
people came up with this concept uh
around the same time maybe other people
too
you know there's babbage and so on and
others who um you know out of love lies
also who came up with notions of
programming but i think is a little
different than um
uh than this in concept but anyway
uh this nevertheless played an important
role in the history of the subject
so with that i think we're at a time i'm
going to um uh quickly review where
we've been um so we should just show the
decidability of various problems
um these are all languages that we uh
showed are decidable we showed that atm
is touring recognizable and i think that
was all we had for today um
so um i will uh we will
stop right here
i will stick around take a few questions
and our tas can take a few questions if
you want by chat
um and then i also have my office hours
which will start in like five minutes or
so once i get everything set up on my
head
um
okay
somebody wanted me to review this point
here which i'm happy to do
um
uh
you know
this code here that i'm describing in
english
um
needs to be something that you can
implement
on a turing machine
um
you know we're never going to go through
the
effort of
building the transition functions and
the states and so on but we need to be
sure that we could if
if we had to
and
how could you make
a turing machine do the test
that m doesn't hold
that's something we don't know how to do
i mean
i can see if m holds
enter i mean i can during the simulation
i can see that m has entered the
q reject state or the q accept state so
i can tell
while i'm simulating that it has halted
but
you know how would the machine or how
would you
know
that m is now how would you you know
someone says well
do x if m never holds
well how do you know him how how can you
do the test
that m is not holding
um
not
there's no obvious way to do that in
fact there is no way to do that but you
know as it stands right now you know the
proof would be on you
to um
to show how to implement that on a
machine and there's just no obvious way
to do that so i think that's why you
should you should only put down things
here which you're sure you could
implement
um
you know even if it might take a long
time so you don't have to worry about
how long it would take but you have to
put things down that you are sure you
could at least implement in principle
so someone has asked me about um
the equivalence problem for context-free
grammars uh being unsolvable
uh why couldn't the machine be a
human-level system of logic
so that
the computer could logically deduce
whether or not it was decidable
um
well
sort of that
you know we're taking a turn into
the subject of mathematical logic which
is supposed to kind of
uh formalize reasoning in a way um and
uh
in the end what it really is kind of
come down to that
there are certain
uh grammars
uh which are
equivalent
to one another
but
there's not going to be any way to prove
that they're equivalent in any
reasonable system
um
in equivalence you can always prove
right you can exhibit a string
that one you can show that this grammar
is generating it this grammar is not
generating
this other one is not so uh in
equivalence you can always prove but
equivalence
there are going to be certain pairs of
grammars which are going to be
beyond the capability of any reasonable
formal system to be able to prove that
they're equivalent because you can even
convert them and make those grammars
into something which talk about the
system itself
ultimately you're going to end up you
know with a russell paradox kind of
thing that's maybe going beyond more
than you want to know and i'm happy to
talk about it offline but you know
there's just no way to make a turing
machine which is going to implement sort
of human reasoning and then get the
right answer on all pairs of grammars
just cannot be done
bye bye i'm going to shut down the
meeting though
you